season five of the mass singer is
officially underway with a brand new
group of star-studded celebrities
wearing masks trying to trick us and
let's jump
right into the first unmasking of the
season sadly the snail did have to
escargo home
what
[Applause]
kermit the frog a muppet and a puppet
singing on the mask singer deidre this
was not on my 2021 prediction bingo card
but i'm not upset about it no i kermit
is an icon i think they're thinking of
so many
innovative ways to outdo themselves on
this show i never
expected a muppet on the mass singer but
here we are
and i'm standing it i'm scanning it and
i hope elmo is there next
my personal favorite of the night the
seashell immediately my best guess
is janelle parish so of course there's
the seashell lots of references to
being by the shore a tsunami janelle is
a very proud
hawaiian american proud of that culture
talking about finding her solace by
the shore um i also honed in on the fact
that um there was a broom and if you
know janelle you know that she played
young cossette in a production of les
mis the most
famous image of les mis is of young
costed holding that broom so that right
there kind of tipped me
off and lastly it was the absence
of any pretty little liars or any to all
the boys i've loved before clues i think
the clue writers are getting smarter and
smarter and they're intentionally
leaving those out
for future episodes who was your
favorite charlie my pick of the night is
someone who gave us a
let's say rabid performance the raccoon
who i believe
is hollywood tough guy and actor danny
trejo
now we saw in the clue package he was in
a jail cell we heard a lot about time in
jail
danny has been very open about the 11
years he spent
in and out of the prison system and
something going with the jail we heard
about the hunchback of notre dame
danny has also spoken about his time in
solidary confinement and how the
hunchback and the wizard of
oz are two stories he would re-read over
and over
and they helped him get through that
time he said he would even act them out
alone in his jail cell
now post-jail life for dany he is a
restaurateur and an entrepreneur
and he actually has something called
trejos coffee and donuts
in west hollywood california and we saw
that donut clue right at the start of
the package
yes and i have been i can vouch it is
absolutely delicious
of course this is just the first of many
weeks ahead that we're gonna be
unraveling the clues and figuring out
who the celebrities behind the masks are
you know charlie and i will always be
keeping you up to date with our best
thoughts and predictions
you can find us on twitter and instagram
i'm at deidre behar
and i'm at charles a o'keefe make sure
to send us all your guesses and be sure
to tune into the download where we're
breaking down everything
mass singer of course remember to stay
safe and in true
mass singer fashion wear a mask